so there's this
subreddit that i go to and i love it
it's called
uh fat fire and the idea is people who
want to retire relatively young with a
lot of money so they can live a fat life
without working and so basically if you
post on there a lot the mods the
community leaders of the subreddit will
verify your net worth to make your sure
you're not full of by the way did
you have a goal like this like i want to
retire by x age or i want to be like
yeah this wealthy by this age what was
your like how did you phrase your goal
uh i i wanted to have 20 million dollars
by age 30.
gotcha all right that's what i wanted
that was my goal i created that goal
when i was in my uh when i was like 19
or 20 years old
i mean i can't confirm or deny but you
know mission accomplished is what i
would say i sold my company i achieved
it at 31 i sold my company at 31. right
um and so my that was my goal because i
asked
a rich person who i knew i asked him how
much money do you spend a month
and they told me 60 000 a month and at
the time i was like i don't know like i
can't imagine there's a world where i
would just weird yeah yeah i'm like that
just sounds crazy but whatever like i
asked like eight people and this person
had the highest number and i was like
okay i'll just do that because i'll be
conservative and then
uh a percentage of your portfo of your
liquid portfolio and basically it
continues to grow have enough money
that the
earnings the the the sort of compounding
earnings on the money being invested in
something safe like the stock market s p
500 type of thing
can um
can cover your burn rate so there's two
things that matter what is the what is
the amount that i have invested and what
is my life burn rate that's why a lot of
people who like fire they go move to
like you know bum you know middle
of nowhere and they they're like oh yeah
i got rid of my car and it's great now i
can you know i got rid of everything i
own and me and my wife we only eat apple
cores and now we were retired it's like
but fat fire is different fat fire is
like now i kind of want to ball out i'm
not trying to like skimp on my lifestyle
so okay what do i need to achieve and
what do i need to optimize while still
not giving up
like what i find to be enjoyable in
terms of lifestyle
yeah so that's how i made up that number
and i don't even i spend 15 000 a month
i mean when i sold i had saved a
like seven figures of course that
includes my wife and i and she also uh
worked at airbnb and so airbnb went
public and she had worked there for a
long time airbnb went public in december
i sold my company in february so it was
like
on december 1st and then like february
1st it was like that those two or three
months was like massive right and so but
prior to that or that it take her out
because we don't want to put her
business out there so let's just talk
about you um
in your early 20s what were you making
so um from age 22 to probably 26 and 27
i paid myself something like two grand a
month so in the brain so the first year
of business i probably paid myself
twenty thousand dollars for the first
year and then i paid myself forty
thousand dollars for the next two years
and then um
seventy thousand dollars and then the
last year that was 24k a year and then
40k a year and then you said 70k roughly
you know it was like 20 40 40 70. yeah
so that's four years in and then the
year we sold i paid myself close to 300
thousand dollars right
and i had a few other investments like
some angel investments and um
like some weird things that kind of paid
off but basically like for the longest
time i mean i was living i the way i
rigged it was in san francisco my rent
was only 400 because i rented out this
big place and i only had 25 grand of my
name and i spent all of it to rent out
and furnish this place and then i rented
it out to people who basically
subsidized it for me so i was living
like a poor person and um so i was able
to save a little bit of money living
like like a wealthy person really you
were living in a place and it was only
costing you 400 a month which is great
example by the way because there's a lot
of people that will be like
i want to move to san francisco but i
can't afford it
all you're saying to me is
i lack creativity and resourcefulness
because what you did is available to
everybody
go find a place that's at market or
slightly below market price
and what you did i think is you cut a
deal with the landlord you were like
i'll never call you for anything yeah i
told it breaks i'll fix it i think you
live there for like a decade or some
and you'd never like set like seven
years never spoke to the person yeah i
never saw him i had not one said have i
ever seen him actually if he showed up
at the house you wouldn't know who that
guy is i would not i don't even remember
what he looks like i couldn't even tell
you what he looks like i think his name
was chris and so you cut this deal and
you're like look i'm you basically
became the landlord well i showed i
showed up and i was 22 and it was a four
thousand dollar or five i forget how
much was it forty five hundred dollars a
month for a four bedroom house and he
goes is it just you i go
look it's just me right now but i'm
gonna get like some friends to move in
um i'll like sign a lease a sublease
with them and i and i can have you
approve it right but basically like i'm
gonna pay you on time all the time and
my the preferred relationship you and i
have is i never see you again
and are you okay with that and he goes
yeah he goes don't don't be late and i
go okay deal anyway it yeah and so at
this point yeah so it was a slow build
it took like five six seven years but
then what's crazy is i'm 32 now i
started hustling at age 20
probably 20 like making like real money
on my own like livable money and
at this point at age 32 i'll make more
this year from a couple like side
investments like a real estate deal that
i did i'll make more this year than
collectively all of my salaries combined
while working at the hustle exactly and
that's that's the exact same same case
for me and i think that's actually
really common and i think the reason i
bring that up is because
it's interesting to me b
i think that's really comforting to
people because when you're in it and
you're not making any money and it looks
like other people are all making hell of
money it feels it could feel very bad
and you can question if you're on the
right path or not and this doesn't mean
you're definitely on the right path but
it means
when this path of entrepreneurship works
that's commonly what it looks like so
don't be surprised um all right so let's
get back to
which by the way um when i was getting
going i was always so envious
of
other people like my friends i'm like
you got a job at google you make
150 grand a year and you have all these
benefits i haven't been to the doctor
forever this is awesome i'm so jealous
so you would come to you'd come to my
office and you'd be like dude this is
your office and yeah yeah and then we'd
be eating something you'd be like this
is this cheese just always available
whose cheese is this
they just bring you cheese i felt like i
would be like you'd be like look this
cheese is from whole foods this is
expensive cheese i'm like bro
stop talking about the cheese right now
but it was like i remember you were
noticing
all those things in a funny way i was
like you guys have an espresso machine
he's got a woman's bathroom what the
hell is this
machine yeah i remember i was like
freaking out that you had an expression
like espresso machine i was like what
the hell is this and i remember like i
used to take food to go
so anyway
um yeah it accumulated quickly
and i think it for most people it's i
mean it
like i think that it's basically it's
like you're poor you're poor you're poor
and then it's like suddenly it's like oh
holy crap i'm not anymore and you know
you have that moment and there's a
subreddit called fat fire and they talk
a lot about that and there's this guy
who has a series of threads called
confessions of a hecto millionaire and
he's doing like eight parts and i linked
to it in there i see
five here yeah and the mods have
basically um approved it so basically
the mods have like this guy dm'd him
dm'd his
accountants or account information or
something so they like verified that
he's uh as wealthy as he is but
basically in the beginning uh thread he
says um you know i'm
worth north of 100 million dollars i got
wealthy originally because i was an
employee at a tech company that made me
30 million dollars and that was like 15
years ago and then i invested in this
and then i did this and then i did this
and i'm gonna answer a lot of the
questions that i think a lot of people
ask here and the mods have approved that
i am who i am and i'm gonna tell you all
about work and purpose my time and
routine why i keep a low profile how
relationships are complicated what i
spend on a monthly basis um what my
investment in portfolio management is
and it's incredibly fascinating i love
this stuff where you get behind the
scenes of people you normally never have
access to and so it's a great series
it's a great thread
it's awesome